quantum computing is getting quite a lot
of coverage these days in the media
which i think is fantastic but when I
read some of the things there are a few
things that are a bit wrong and I'm not
really criticizing anyone quantum
computing is very hard but I think
there's some room for some more nuance
so here are my top five clarifications
about quantum computing and standard
description of quantum computing
normally goes something like this
quantum computers are made of qubits
which can be in a state of 0 & 1 at the
same time all of the qubits are then
entangled so they're all treated as a
single object that's in many different
states at the same time therefore a
quantum computer is like an infinitely
parallel computer and they're not quite
right so it's true that kuan computers
are in multiple states at the same time
before you measure them but as soon as
you measure them you only get one state
back parallel computing deals with
breaking down large problems into small
chunks which can each be solved on a
processor before the whole thing's
recombined but the architecture is very
different to quantum computers in a
parallel computer you've got many
different independent processes running
at the same time rather than an
entangled state and also you can read
out any of the states of any of the
processes at any time you like number 2
imagine this situation you've got
someone who says they've developed a
quantum algorithm that needs a hundred
qubits in order to run and you've got
another person who says I've built this
one computer and it's got hundred qubits
in it so any normal person would say ok
great you can just take that algorithm
and put it on that machine and get an
answer but in most cases that's really
not true and it's because they're
talking about two different kinds of
qubits in the algorithm sense what
they're talking about is an theoretical
ideal qubit which is commonly referred
to as a logical qubit whereas in a
quantum computer sense they're talking
about a real physical device which could
be like a loop of men
to an atom and electron photon something
like that and these physical qubits have
noise in them because they they're real
devices living in the real world and
noise is a killer for quantum algorithms
it will destroy your quantum state so
people are all trying to make qubits
with as low noise possible but the
quality of a qubit matters a huge amount
to how good your quantum computer is now
theoretically there's a way of getting
around noise in qubits using a technique
called quantum error correction which is
where you use multiple physical qubits
to simulate one logical qubit and how
many physical qubits you actually needs
to simulate a logical qubit depends on
how good quality those physical qubits
are the higher quality they are the few
you need the estimates range from say
10,000 physical qubits to a hundred
physical qubits per logical qubit that
brings me on to 0.3 which is quantum
computers and Internet encryption so a
lot of the internet encryption is based
on the fact that it's really hard to
factor large numbers on a classical
computer and this is quantum algorithm
called Shaw's algorithm that can
theoretically factor these large numbers
exponentially fast and the best
classical algorithm the trouble is for a
standard 128 bit encryption you'd need
about a thousand cubits for Shor's
algorithm to run and that means that
you'd need a million or more physical
qubits in order to run it and that's a
really massive number of qubits
currently we have the best is 72 qubits
that Google has in the universal quantum
computing scheme and so it's going to be
a very long time until we hit a million
so for the time being your internet
secrets are safe point number four is
the fact that nobody knows for sure that
con computing will ever work at scale
some people argue that noise is such a
significant issue that'll be impossible
to get say a million cubits all working
together without noise coming along and
ruining everything and it's a fair point
personally I'm
optimistic human ingenuity can go a very
long way some people said that we would
never detect gravitational waves on
earth because noise is a too significant
issue for that and yet the people at
LIGO did an absolutely incredible job
over many years and now we can detect
gravitational waves on earth which is an
amazing achievement it's not exactly
equivalent to quantum computing but you
know the only way we can find out
whether we can do it is by trying to do
it and like I say oh I'm optimistic but
it's always worth bearing in mind that
it's not guaranteed and the final point
I want to make is about quantum
supremacy now I think quantum supremacy
is a bad name because it poorly
describes the thing that it's trying to
describe I've done a whole video on
quantum supremacy so check that out if
you want to find more details about it
but basically it's the moment in time
where a quantum computer can do one
thing better than the best classical
supercomputers can do now currently
classical computers can do everything a
quantum computer can do and more but if
you think about quantum supremacy makes
it sound like it's the time when a
quantum computer can do everything a
classical computer can do and more but
that's really not what it is it's the
time when a quantum computer can do one
tiny little thing better than a
classical computer so it shouldn't
really be called quantum supremacy it
should be called something more like a
quantum glimmer of hope or a lot of
people are calling it a quantum
advantage which i think is probably a
better name well I hope that cleared up
a few things
gave you a bit more subtlety into what
Cantus can and can't do personally I'm
really excited about where quantum
computer is going to go in the future I
think the potential applications of it a
massive especially in the realm of
quantum simulation because that's
something that we really struggle to do
on classical computers because quantum
quantum systems are so hard to simulate
quantum computer can do it a lot better
theoretically and that could be
revolutionary in say like simulating
materials to find out what properties
different material
have with strength durability or exotic
things like high-temperature
superconductors also in chemistry if you
could simulate how molecules interact
say a molecule in a drug how that
interacts with many different
biomolecules in your body that would be
an amazing thing to do in something we
can't do right now so I'm very excited
to see what happens in the future I'll
keep you updated here thanks again to
the sponsor of this video brilliant org
what they've done is taken proper maths
and science and put it in this framework
where it pretty much feels like you're
solving puzzles but you're solving real
problems for math and science and
learning real STEM skills and when I'm
looking for a brain teaser I like doing
their problems of the week and the
problems range from being very
approachable through to some stuff that
isn't legitimately difficult they also
have courses on physics mathematics
computer science and they're adding more
content all the time and the thing I
love is when you're doing a hard problem
and you finally see how to solve it you
crack the problem and you get it right
and you have a moment of feeling like
yes I'm not complete idiot and that's
what I enjoy so if that sounds
interesting go to brilliant org slash do
s and I've also put a link in the
description below thanks for watching my
video and I will see you on the next one
[Music]